wait what the heck why do you what do
both of you think that I mean okay guess
I'm learning things about myself today
[Music]
we are here to see who knows me best my
boyfriend or my dad so we're figuring
out if he knows me better my mom or my
boyfriend Carlos my boyfriend Dakota and
I have been together for about four and
a half years Carlos and I have been
dating for two years and a week because
I just had our anniversary last week I
would say he knows me
way better than my dad my dad has
obviously been there for like all those
monumental life moments but all the
details and the nitty-gritty stuff about
my life my boyfriend definitely knows my
brother well after you date somebody for
a while you just kind of like wives just
start to melt
I hope Dakota with it if he doesn't know
the majority of things about me that
kind of sucks we've been together for so
long I feel like they're gonna be very
mixed like my mom is probably gonna go
with like answers that would have
applied when I was like 12 and then my
boyfriend knows me better now my dad and
I are really close
I go down to see him every single
weekend we spend like almost every
single meal together when I'm down there
so my mom and I are really close we talk
pretty much every day I call her like
every single break that I have I don't
know why like I don't consider myself
like a mama's boy but like looking at
from like an outsider perspective I
probably have let's see who in
[Music]
question number one what is my favorite
meal of a question you guys ready three
two one No oh that's your favorite I'm
gonna go one two three wow that was a
close ghost yeah she that every morning
yeah this way this question artist is
she changed their mind all the time so
it's not what she has liked historically
historically it's like what are you
feeling right now if so for lunch you
want to get pokies all you're saying
yeah okay if I won the lottery what's
the first thing I would buy I feel like
it's really easy okay well you got to
start off slow and then we'll get into
the hard one you get too confident and
it's gonna bite you in the butt later
okay you're answering really quickly I
feel like you're not I don't know
somebody yeah you're not thinking it
better be this answer if it's not I
didn't teach her too well I don't know
any course we can we miss it three two
one zero one two three oh yeah it's a
hollow father knows best hand boyfriend
what's my favorite way to relax and
recharge my batteries because I don't
know that's easy I feel like my
handwriting is getting sloppier now
three two one all right but that
actually it would be the right answer
that's actually true I didn't but
meditating on the beach
we know you oh that's sweet yeah no you
guys have to do some introspective time
after this would I consider myself more
of an introvert extrovert I'm really
about what's pretty easy what if I just
throw it and write the wrong line
three two one two three what wait what
the heck why do you both of you think
that because regularly people think that
your next revert but actually exactly
you're in a natural introvert and you
like to spend time about yourself I mean
okay guess I'm learning things about
myself today yes what do you think is my
worst trait I don't like that question
feel free to offend me okay what do we
think or what do you think what do I
think
I didn't answer this is so me I had to
win I'm not oh you're never crouching
what no Carlos gets that point can he
got that point oh I could have got it
I'm too bossy are you sad because I boss
you around or what type of adventure
would I prefer a spontaneous one or a
carefully planned out one you feel
confident about this there your
confident one two three
what oh you got it why'd you put a
spontaneous because you like to be
spontaneous and do thing you want me to
plan things out for you and just how
much you know but it's still planned out
I'm planning it out but it for you to
think yes because you have no idea I
mean I guess but I need someone to plan
something plan on what frightens me most
No and you only choose one wait only one
yeah I would I think I'm scared of
multiple things
well frightened frightened is different
that's easy you think it's easy I don't
think either of you will get it you're
just reading anything great about it
after you wrote it yeah okay one two
three I put my dad spiders actually I
probably should have guessed that yeah
what you care do this all the time yeah
but I'm scared of you more oh that's
respect no on three two one supporting
right I was I didn't yeah you got it
right
four and a half years and you can't even
win a game of course I got I did pretty
good though no you actually did you and
some of these questions are hard
actually yeah well done I'm actually
very surprised my dad won I'm surprised
they can both answer some of the
questions because I felt like some of
them were really hard and like super
super specific sorry Debbie there was a
good you both know me better than I know
myself
I guess we are closer than I think we
are picked up that I'm not surprised
okay okay the game's over you don't have
to be mean to each other
[Music]